[Musik]
doch sehr fasziniert obwohl man
eigentlich nicht die gleiche sprache
das extrem gut verstanden nun werde ich
relativ klima ersichtlich dass es
einfluss auf mich
[Musik]
zeltweg
islam
[Musik]
die kalorien
der sonne libido grenzen überwindet kann
ein ort bringen warum es nicht die treue
im alu wir nicole und der rasche story
auf sansibar weil es neu die größte
waffe rapperswil der legal und dass die
schweiz ihren marashi mit ihrer tochter
lila führe zwei jahren sansibar als
hotel
[Musik]
trotzdem nicole ihre liebe zum wasser
sind so ausflug aus familie selten
teilnimmt beide in beschlag
[Musik]
wenn ich weg bin sagte sie und
umgeknickt lila oder der queen
[Musik]
aber fakt ist dass der preis des
familienlebens polizeiinspektion sie hat
macht ihn scalzo
jetzt erlebt er kostet es mich bei
meiner arbeit als wirklich zu viel
manchmal bis zu 16 stunden
auch hier arbeite ich viel von morgens
früh bis abends wenn ich abschließen
das zwingt nicht manchmal darüber
nachzudenken was ich hier überhaupt
machen es genau das gleiche
ich habe gekündigt alle meine freunde
und familie in marokko zurück gelassen
für dich ein großes auto für nicole ist
das hier der traum am stand zu leben und
ein hotel zu führen
für dich nicht nein das nicht
nein das kann ich so nicht akzeptieren
achtung ich verstehe schweizerdeutsch
da gibt es offenbar noch nie
informations spiel klar ist ob familie
schmitte lila komplex und den stramm dem
zaun inklusive aller tropischen aquarium
reloaded zum abtauchen und allfälligem
ist unvergessen
[Musik]
natürlich war ich sehr nervös als ich
dich damals am flughafen abgeholt habe
wir dachten oh mein gott wir haben nun
das gleiche hotel zimmer für drei tage
was ist wenn es nicht klappt was ist
wenn wir uns miserabel fühlen und am
liebsten sofort wieder nach hause gehen
würden ja ja ich finde sie hat als
letzten wir entschieden uns dafür es
locker zu nehmen und einfach die tage zu
genießen
[Musik]
wir verabredeten auch dass wir wenn wir
uns am flughafen sehen mal gar nichts
sagen würden bis zum mittagessen und
erst beim mittagessen sprachen wir
darüber wie wir uns fühlen genau so
machen wir es dann
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nur ghadir vorne und das baufeld
erinnert wieder florence die highlights
der dinge annik los
sie wohnt mit ihrer tochter nova rock
mit sage und schreibe 7
[Musik]
apple zwei männer 30 florence für das
verlängerte wochenende später zu ihrem
mann der abschieds auf 10 für das
bauwerk ist schwer und sensibel was
nicht gern hätte wenn ich nicht immer
aber mit dem grossisten hat seine sache
toll gemacht
ich glaube die ganze runde chance hat
alle mini bb und damit jedem wenn man
sich ab und zu soll ein vermisst aber
zum glück hat florence hilft mir mich
und nach halt und sie wohnt mit tony
ward b und lust zu erhöhen und gemüse
und vierter schlafdauer hier also führt
österreich so die super perfekte lösung
aber das ist das wichtigste
schwester für mich tochter dass sie ihre
[Gelächter]
vorlieben und das ist für mich eine
super lösung
30 hoch gottes früh
[Musik]
und dann klappt es doch endlich habt zum
flughafen
[Musik]
wünsche der stadt im süden von schweden
der betrieb der nicolas zimmer mit dem
bruder adam glaserei die beiden erst vor
kurzem mit einem betrieb angefangen und
sie sind 30 kundschaft oft leben und
schaffen es schwede hat eine frau in der
schweiz geraten ist wir starteten vor
einem jahr
und wir sind seither gut ausgebucht ich
dachte nie daran aber wenn ich in der
schweiz leben würde bräuchte ich eine
arbeit
das hier ist mein job und genau das
müsste ich auch wieder machen können
das ist das was ich kann
ich führte auch ein reisebüro ich
trackings in der ganzen welt
organisierte trekking in nepal und
tansania
ich habe auch überlegt dieses geschäft
auszubauen und ein bisschen mehr zu
klettern
aber dann habe ich florence getroffen
und die sache hat sich geändert
jetzt möchte ich nicht mehr irgendwo in
der welt herumreisen bergsteiger im
himalaya das alles weg
[Musik]
und dir ist schon immer auf luke
wir immer wenn der microsd florence am
flughafen töteberg abholen gibt's ein
blumenstrauß
lastminute blumen eigentlich möchte ich
eine einzelne rose
ich bin nicht nervös ich freue mich
einfach die sind schön
bolat
da kommt sie
[Musik]
du siehst super aus hattest du eine gute
reise
entschuldige meine aufmachung
ich war in der arbeit
ich glaube ich gemacht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das hotel am strand vor sansibar ist not
idee für den xi sehr zu hause damit um
wenn der satz ich weiß nicht was für
geschätzte doch jeden tag daran ja es
ist schon mein geschmack
mein gott du willst es macht ja stolz
es findet rallye thron klar aber dass du
mir kriegt ihr wissen mit mode und
klappe und beschrieben
ja das sind wünsche dass ich eine
familie anerkannt und hat so was macht
das mit reduziert also sicher nicht nur
zu einer beachtlichen geschädigt es ist
und der in marrakesch als einfacher ist
vielleicht auch so würden wir sind ja
wohl kings of leon hat in nordafrika wo
alles viel weiter entwickelt ist und von
tagesschau.de wenn es nicht dass ich
kann mir gar nicht gestellt haben
denn los sei und was mit den machen
die post zwei levels entwurf unter einen
hut bringen
das vermeintliche paradies nicht einfach
der raschid der ehemalige
polizeiinspektor oder marokkanische
sahara hätten moment frucht zum sich mit
den neuen standards freunde
[Musik]
das ist ein neues kapitel in meinem
leben
jetzt bin ich zufrieden und das ist mein
naturell bin immer neugierig zu sehen
wie sich das alles entwickeln wird
[Musik]
es ist in kraft andere und alt die liebe
in der heimat zurück block 3 setzen ihre
freizeit gemacht
[Musik]
das war nicht dein traum sondern der von
nicole warum hast du dich trotzdem
entschieden hier ein neues leben
anzufangen
erstens wollte ich sowieso aus dem
polizeidienst aussteigen zweitens bin
ich jemand der nicht allzu lange
nachdenkt vor einer entscheidung
und drittens wusste ich dass nicole eine
starke frau ist die mir auch helfen
würde die ersten schritte zu machen
das promi-paar
der nikolaus zum stellige leichter
gefallen als ihrem mann will sie als
geschäftsführerin vom hotel eine klar
definierte aufgabe wo sie mit viel power
pack damit nimmt sie mich mit einer
sogenannten ladies night ist reif für
businessfrauen das ist doch alles ist
das geschäftsjahr sind die portierung
hier klicken
der abschied von der behörde lanka
offiziellen tanzbewegung überruh und
roma nicht richtig schönes geschäft die
stiege und damit willkommen
und das nagt am selbstbewusstsein
polizeiinspektion finde ich total
gesperrt
[Gelächter]
also es ist auch keiner im juni wollen
die hessischen landtag origins und wenn
man die lange gewusst was er eigentlich
macht in der grafik offiziellen
aufspüren
interessant ist mit einem sekunden
das macht es so dass du einen tragischen
ehrung mit du bist das hin und her den
sie mit ihm über eigene lager und los
ist das match aber nach zwölf jahren
zetia und im lot
ich glaub mir repräsentieren wie die
meisten nach zwei jahre dauerte es bis
das ist einfach ein flottes talkshow
es ist einfach sind es super gut
funktionieren die familie sagt wir
machen
romantisch ist aus vielitz die für oboe
und ich spüre dass nicole unterschied
auch ohne schmetterlinge im buch durchs
band verbunden sind
[Musik]
mit
ich glaube du hast selber vorgeschlagen
dass du nach schweden kommen wirst wenn
wir zusammenziehen
bist du sicher ja keine diskussion
perfekt schneller bist weder wo es liegt
im gebiet tanner gesagt sie das ist
eigentlich mal klimas thema xiii und
natürlich option das land und eigentum
hier in schweden schwing liche risch aus
der schweiz die möglichkeit das half uns
zusammen weiterzumachen
hättest du gesagt ich werde meinen lang
nie verlassen und ich hätte das gleiche
gesagt hätten wir ein großes problem
gehabt
wahrscheinlich hätten wir uns sagen
müssen
bekanntlich ist es andersrum und so hat
sich auch im hin und her pendle zwischen
tübingen und jünger bin schon eine art
routine nie gestellt
[Musik]
und auch david florence nicht auf hunde
lieber verzichten
das sind geschenke von florence mutter
dass auch das ist von florence und das
habe ich an einer party in der schweiz
geklaut
da ist die schokolade gefunden was ich
nicht mag habe ich die übrig gelassen
[Gelächter]
ich fühle mich nicht als single
auch wenn wir uns fünf oder sechs wochen
nicht sehen wir sprechen jeden tag
zusammen
wir beenden den tag gemeinsam auch aus
distanz wir wissen was beim anderen
passiert ich fühle mich ihr na ich weiß
wie ihre tage aussehen und sie kennt
meine idee ist droht in und laufs
umfunktioniert und ja das schwede wieder
kreditbank und wenn hier oben bist doch
mitverantwortlich der heimabgabe oder
abschalten und du bist eigentlich zu
100% hier
und das geht nach wie vor in saada
konflikt wenn weder hyflux oder wenn
unser fliegt eigentlich braucht
ich würde sagen im alltag funktionieren
also es ist schon nicht so ganz einfach
[Musik]
zwei york rechnet sich die zwei jetzt im
nächsten juni ins kino
[Musik]
gerade
[Gelächter]
jetzt haben sie
häufig der
max der uci maxim beck blog
regelmäßig traf es eigentlich immer wenn
ich hier bin
fühle mich sehr sehr gut kooperiert
er wird erklären
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sportlich gesehen nicht unbeliebt wie
viele trachten freundin wo ihn erkannt
hat gesagt du nicht triffst dich mal
okay und ich bin mir das stück sind die
hosen gemacht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
14 jähriger sei
sie trug zum ersten mal wieder vor der
tür gestanden ist sido ist sichere mit
mein base caps profizeit langhans miami
bleibt will die gruppe bei den miami
heat und vertrag hat und dort sie jetzt
claudia immer noch häufig jetzt aber für
das eigene geschäft sie ist es catering
bis musikstücke
[Musik]
wenn man ganz schön worden und tritt nun
ad und holz bis business sich sehr gut
mit athleten viele andere superstar
singen wo sich dann auch sportchef
leiste wand
claudia ist ursprünglich nicht weg der
sache sie ist zirkusartistin und
tänzerisch sie und setzt sich die
vereinigten staaten karrieren aufbaut
bis am valentinstag ein großes leben ist
irgendwie in amerika des großes thema
los angeles und das ist ein
folgenschwerer zu erfahren die zwei sind
jetzt sind überzeugt kurorte und hat
zwei töchter
[Musik]
ich bin ich habe mich einfach ist er ist
auch so eine gehalts ist es ist so ruhig
totale gegenteil von mir eigentlich oder
immer alles klasse nicht einen satz
abgegeben und mal schnell
[Musik]
der club oder die ganzen namen acrobat
javascript profi eine botschaft aus
frankreich hätten sie nie karriere in
italien bis die amerikanische national
basketball league führt die beste liga
der welt jetzt kriegsende vor seiner
aktivkarriere und normale user fordert
ihn warten
ein abstecher und afrika
[Musik]
es wäre das erste mal dass die npd nach
afrika gehen würde
ich bin sehr aufgeregt auch meine
freunde aus senegal wo meine familie
ursprünglich herkommt ich kann es kaum
erwarten den leuten etwas zurückzugeben
in new york wurde krupp unbedingt packen
ich bin in frankreich aufgewachsen meine
frau ist aus der schweiz und meine
kinder sind in den usa geboren
wir sind also total gemischt deshalb
interessiert mich abgehakt
ein weiterer kontinent je mehr man sieht
verschiedene kulturen offen sein
gegenüber anderen
das ist das beste ich hätte nie gedacht
dass basketball mir das ermöglicht
ich kann mich wirklich glücklich
schätzen
[Applaus]
wie schon so manish ist ja kuba allein
tracks weg für seine frau claudia und
seine beiden töchter
hallo ich traf den präsidenten der
afrikanischen basketball liga er sah
meinen namen wusste nicht dass ich
wirklich hier bin kuba bist du wirklich
so schön dass du da bist so weit so gut
alles geht bestens und wir haben spaß
mal sehen was passiert wie gehts mit dem
kaufen
ich habe gerade einen fisch mit 280
dollar gekauft ein toter fisch
sie kocht
basketball als lebe vom jacoba völlig
auf den kopf stellt als sohn vor
senegalesische anderer parisi
einfachsten verhältnissen aufgewachsen
geldsorgen sind judt kraft thema bleibe
für meine superstar nachteil das blöde
ist man es dem weg hab zeit verschieben
facetime und skype sind schon gut aber
natürlich nicht das gleiche aber eben
wir haben dieses leben selber gewählt
uns hat niemand gezwungen
wir wussten beide werfen uns einlassen
alles hängt zusammen
die ganze verantwortung die liebe bleibt
natürlich aber das lässt sich mit der
verantwortung den problemen der freude
mit der arbeit auch mit dem erfolg des
hotels die beziehung wird immer
vielschichtiger
juni dann noch songs wir sind erwachsene
menschen
es gibt augenblicke der liebe und der
freude aber es gibt neben den höhen auch
tiefen
das ist einfach so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alltag auf sansibar gute million
menschen leben dort praktisch alles sind
muslime lebt vom tourismus ein
wichtigste wirtschaftsfaktor zum raschen
aufgabe kürzeste die meisten leute redet
zwar hier aber mit arabisch oder
englisch
[Musik]
nicolai stunden
mit dem mit der kokosnuss wenn jede
stadt darum
dann nicht
st
wir haben hier
es gibt 2 35
womit man geht
das ist
logisch sind zufrieden damit ameling
wie gut die ohren werden
ja und screen auf
für
ein nie zum schiff brauche schuhe für
die leute in der küche und zwar ziemlich
viele
sie haben die normalen crocs auch hier
gibt es pläne kontrollen fensterreden
eine schlappe wollte zwar hat die cs
problem mit dem mit dem staat zu wenn
sie kontrolliert
wie viel kostet das auch wenn ich zwölf
stück nehme kosten sie 66
geben sie mir 63 63
obwohl sie engadget hat nicole und der
asche auch ihre freies leben auf
sansibar unterscheidet sich fundamental
von dem wo sie sich gewöhnt sind nun
will sie gemeinsam das hotel führen
positiv oder negativ
aber das mache sagt einfach
wir haben das gemeinsam ins neue heim
das ist vorbei das ist gar nicht zu
stellen
da man aufgabe hat stolz sein und singen
und zirkus eigentlich alles was ich
geschrieben wird sagte zum spiel
erwerben oder spielen ganze ja und ich
kannten
claudia ist auf dem weg sie zirkusartist
ins werde
sie hat für stars wie destiny's child
oder jaycee musikvideos tanzt und summe
bis zu dem moment wurde coup ihres
lebens
hinter den es mit zum besten claudia ist
in sri lanka geboren und als baby von
schweizer eltern adoptiert wurde
ich würde immer mehr fasziniert sie vom
zirkus will das ist irgendwie im knie es
ist der einzige und liegen auch mit den
grund sind das sehen und traumata und
das hat sie geschafft sogar videos bis
in ca
denn nichts
was sie mit dem endspiel am zoo gehege
in ihrer not be used sie zur basketball
kann sowie professionelle spieler
deutlich bekanntes business probleme als
das gar nicht sagt jörg real turner für
den zirkus er spielte basketball
überhaupt nicht gewusst wo es mich
plötzlich ist der club nur einfach ihre
neue frank sie hat auch ein richtiger
job übernahm oder spielerfrau alle
danken es ist schön mit den
ganztagsschulen und schöne kleider und
das land schnell und gut aber auch gar
nicht
man muss immer nur gezeigt gut ist dass
der schlaf machen später vorm spiel man
muss immer nett sie man muss sich
zurückziehen und somit das ist
kompliziert ganze 30 nur um ihn und
alles was ab passt werde um ihn und
wieso steht verlierer sind so große
persönlichkeit hat
[Musik]
eigentlich sieht mir nach see bis zwei
jahre nach der periode entweder
wirtschaft beruhe forderte partners
halte die einfachen menschen und jetzt
machen wir mit botschaft
zu ruhig offensichtlich nutzt sie für
den igel
[Musik]
vor langenberg der schuh mit li na ja
also ihr werdet ihr pensionierter
express der nächste ort wie meinst du
dass dort wo es eine gute schule gibt
wie lila das ist kein problem für mich
aber nochmals das gleiche wie hier
möchte ich nicht mehr ich möchte am
liebsten nach marokko oder wenigstens in
die nähe nicht mehr 13 14 flugstunden
entfernt es ist nicht einfach mit meiner
familie meiner mutter die schwester
unsere kultur ist einfach anders
wir sind sehr familien verbunden mein
vater ist verstorben
ich möchte mich um meine mutter kümmern
das gibt sie nicht so richtig klar also
dass ich vor 24 jahren wieder
miteinander diskutieren und irgendeinen
kompromiss finden nein danke sowie zu
wir dürfen nicht suchen es wird sich
ergeben
so war es auch mit sansibar so ist das
leben
europa ist kein problem
[Musik]
ich zweifle keinen moment dass nicole
und terrazzino viele spannende projekt
vor sich hält und auch noch viele
diskussionen aber ohne das nötige pecik
wo verschiedene kulturen zu einem
kompromiss machen und können verzichten
ist brice fürs glück funktion
hin und weg jörg suche eine föderale
moment wo die ganze familie diawara
zähmen ist
hier wird es eine badewanne für hunde
geben
darum liegt sie mich
und durch woche vor und in der schweiz
sogar ohne virus martina und der kerl zu
einer überstürzten news waren
[Musik]
religion ethik machen